have one missing Mele you've been my
patient reflection excellent all right
sir reflection now let's have another
word for a more common rather less
technical one you know very nice
you flip something upside down or back
to front guineas reflected the other
words that yeah Mira very nice I like
that okay I think there's a bunch of
really good city names for it
what's the idea what ingredients do you
need not think about this one carefully
any directions and distances here we
needed an angle an injection of a point
here right what do you need if you want
to reflect something so what you
actually need is a line a straight line
okay
straight line okay once you've got that
straight line you'll know where you get
for example let me draw some really
rough ones over here if I have my
rectangle here right and I reflect
across now you'll need your ruler for
this one how am I gonna work out exactly
where I'm going to go now get your roll
up get your roll up now rectangles are
easy because rectangles are defined by
these one two three four corners right
so what you want to do for each corner
is is take your ruler and then draw a
line from the corner to the line that's
been provided to you okay now here's an
important thing
you control lots of lines from here to
this line but I only want one I'll look
the shortest one how do you know it's
the shortest one there's a word that
we're looking at for shortest distance
how like for instance I can already tell
you that that's not the first distance
right and neither is that right there's
only one that is
what is it's a wedge tiny reason it's
another big one where we learn to
untangle like parallel the arishok
perpendicular good okay this is very
close to travel so he's really going to
do we're gonna draw our line across and
we want to make sure it's perpendicular
to the straight line like so see that
now you can see at least on mine I don't
know if you can see my ruler big enough
it's a it's fourteen centimeters away
from the straight line okay so to make
sure I do the flip to reflection I want
to go another 14 centimeter this way
okay so you can see this line and this
line are the same length
that's really important so if I have
this point over here it's now gonna end
up over there and I'm gonna repeat this
process all the way I'm gonna go across
here get a new point you can see what's
gonna happen okay
so I'll show you exactly I just want to
give you a general overview of how it
works okay I'll show you exactly what's
required for each one when we zoom it
all the more detail okay so on your
reflection the being is a nice metaphor
we need this straight line to go to and
so this to our cells a diagram with the
are again okay let's go this way let's
do it a bit differently no no let's just
go in this direction if I draw the line
here okay there's my straight line what
am I going to get it'll be upside down
okay now mine's a bit rough but
hopefully you'll be able to do yours
nicely just like I illustrated in the
key before right it's actually very
important but you put the new upside
down one in the right spot it wouldn't
be a reflection if this upside down I
was like all the way down here okay
because I wouldn't be reflected across
this line right it'd be like if you're
standing right next to a mirror right in
its face and then your reflection is
like really far away
that's alright alright are there any
questions on that that makes sense
okay
[Music]
you always here that's right it'll be
even line will be somewhere else so by
the way before I had to know him blowing
questions right this is a nice easy line
okay um the lines can be hard sometimes
for instance if I drew this heart up
here and maybe you want to try this with
me actually if I drew that reflecting
line often a we'd angle like this the
odds not going to be upside down and
it's not going to be back to front where
will it be oh yeah you're starting to
see see these these translations sorry
transformation don't relate to each
other let me try and do this in a really
rough way okay there's my perpendicular
line I need to go the same distance in
the opposite way okay I'll do it again
for this point yeah does that look so
far so good what at this point something
like that yeah okay
what's another point I should pick so if
I go from here perpendicular so I'm
struggling a little bit I'm trying to be
as accurate as I can hmm yeah hold on
and have a look we check which other
points that connect here versus here it
looks like I'm gonna get a shape like
this I think you're gonna get something
like that
now stop and look at this really careful
human because this is really interesting
okay as we just said it's not just
upside down that's easy quite back to
front either what is that yeah it looks
to me like two things that have it looks
to me like it's been translated and then
reflected or rotated it's sort of off at
an angle isn't it and that's reflected
by the fact this straight line is all
today okay now that was really rough you
can do a better job when you're actually
doing it with your ruler you can do some
interesting ones okay